next question today should a seat on a
state Supreme Court be an elected
position I don't distinguish between
what should be the policy on the the
National Supreme Court the Supreme Court
of the United States and state supreme
courts I have a real problem with
elections for any kind of judge I think
that that is really problematic however
we know that giving the right to appoint
judges for life to people who happen to
be in office at the time that there's a
vacancy is also really problematic so
rather than focusing on elected versus
appointed I think that there should be
term limits period on appointed
positions the move to elections is
problematic for me because people the
general public makes very bad decisions
all the time at the same time you could
make a case for the election over the
political appointment but I actually
think that a better move would be we
maintain these Supreme Court seats as
political appointments or move them
where they're not to political
appointments but term limit them because
the most corrupting thing most
corrupting factor or influence on
someone who is making these decisions
that for others are life-altering
decisions about sentences and in a
prison time and so on and so forth is
that if the person making the decision
is there for life that is a real problem
you could make the case that if they
know they have an election to answer to
that might make them more accountable
and I'm open to that but term limiting I
actually think is something we should
really be looking at when it comes to
Supreme Court's I also think that if
judges are elected instead of appointed
by the executive be it governor or the
president yep it would throw the entire
balance of power out of whack
like then wouldn't the checks and
balances that we have now wouldn't be
the same because that's the control that
the executive has over the judicial
branch right now that they get to
appoint them and of course the
legislature approves or declines that
that's interesting that's interesting in
it it would change certainly the balance
of power and sort of those checks and
balances whatever your position
I'll let me put it this way I want to
hear from you a
about elected versus appointed Supreme
Court justices at the federal and state
level but what I want to get your
feedback on is what about term limits no
more serving for life whether it's
elected or appointed if it's elected you
can only get reelected a certain number
of times and if it's appointed it only
lasts certain amount of time maybe it's
10 years I understand that a lot of
cases last many years so 10 years to
four or even six-year terms for a US
Supreme Court justice maybe it would be
too seduced short but you got to put a
limit on it because it is a real problem
that we're dealing with